i think that we've all really connected
with eddie for one reason or another
whether we like his music taste or that
he is the outsider like you mentioned
joseph quinn wipes away tears as he
listens to a special message from a
stranger things fan yeah people seem to
be responding to it yeah that's putting
it lightly
what are you even looking for madonna
beetles music we need music
eddie munson played by joseph was a
breakout character in the show's fourth
season and according to one fan he's
someone everyone can relate to
hi
and mine's not really a question
it's just more of a extension of
gratitude really here's joseph attending
a q a at showmaster's comic-con in
london and the vibe quickly turns into a
love fest for the actor
i just wanted to say
thank you from all of us we're really
grateful that you're sharing your time
joseph gets visibly teary-eyed while
listening to the fan's message thank you
for signing our things for spending time
with us for painting our summer
and
i think that we've all really connected
with eddie for one reason or another
whether
we like his music taste or that he is
the outsider like you mentioned i think
all of us are part of eddie you know we
are so grateful um
at the end joseph lightens the mood by
sharing his reaction
very kind of you thank you for your kind
words i never expected this in my career
ever the special moment comes as joseph
is feeling love from around the world
and even some high profile admirers as
his co-star noah snop infamously
revealed doja cat has been crushing on
the actor
it's crazy the season 4 finale of
stranger things kicked off a huge
outpour of love for eddie who spoiler
alert dies a hero during the finale's
epic battle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joseph recently told et just how much
these fan reactions mean to him were you
aware of the amount of love that
that eddie
has there's two main reactions that i'm
seeing
heartbroken and rage at the duffers
yeah i got a text from the doctors a
couple of weeks ago i was saying
we're bracing ourselves
um i don't know it's kind of it's a
completely overwhelming feeling
it's so lovely like the
the devotion of the fans have for the
show and kind of
um how they've found space in their
heart for a new character um eddie is
just so it's heartwarming and um yeah
i don't even know what to say about it
it's been they've been so gracious and
welcoming
it's lovely
[Music]
you